تزايد تمثيل اللاعبين لدولي ابائهم
واجدانهم لا يقتصروا على المغرب فقط 32
لاعبا ولدوا في فرنسا دافعوا عن ثلاثه
منتخبات افريقيه تعود اصولهم لها في
المونديال الحليب هذا الامر يجعل حتى بعض
الاشقاء يدافعون عن دول مختلفه في مونديال
قطر ايضا دلائل وهنا نشاهد الاخوين هناك
وليامز ونيك وليامز الاول اختار ان ان
يمثل ارض الاجداد غانا ام الثانيه تفضل
تمثيل ارض الميلاد والنشر اسبانيا لا
تاريخ المشترك بين غانا واسبانيا ولكن هذه
الحاله استثنائيه في الاغلب تمثل
المستعمرات السابقه خطا امدادا كروي
للمنتخبات الدول المستعمره في فرنسا خير
مثال معظم لاعبيها من اصول الدول
استعمرتها فرنسا سابقا
الدوره الكبيره الذي يلعبون نجوم كره
القدم من اصول المهاجره في المنتخب
الفرنسي فرنسا حصلت على كاس العالم مرتين
الاولى عام
1998 وساهم في ذلك النجم التاريخي زين
الدين زيدان وهو من اصول الجزائريه
والثانيه في عام 2018 حيث ضمت القائمه 14
لاعبا من اصول افريقيه من بين قائمه تضم
23 لاعبا كان ابرزهم كيليان مبابي وهو
كابيرون الاصل ورغم هذه الانجازات التي
ساهم بها المهاجرون الافارقه لا تسال هناك
اصوات وعارضه لهذا الامر وكان تسريب 2011
المثال الاكبر على ذلك التسريب متناول
قرارات يفكر فيها الاتحاد الفرنسي للحكي
من نسبه اللاعبين من اصول عربيه وافريقيه
بنسبه 30% كانت نتيجته هذا التسريب اقاله
المدير الفني للاتحاد الفرنسي وقتها فرنسا
السيناريو تكرر في هولندا استقلت عنها
دوله سورينام في
1975 لكنها لازالت والى اليوم تمثل منجم
مواهب لا ينضب للمنتخب البرتقالي القائمه
الطويله بلجيكا والكونغو البرتغال وكل من
الراس الاخضر وانجولا و موزمبيق الاخيرتان
قدمتا الفهد الاسمر اوزيبيو لكن الصوره
ليست ورديه دائما اختيار المنتخب الوطني
لا يتم براسك بقلبك وهكذا شرحها حكيم زياش
قراره تمثيل وطنه الامه المغرب وليس
هولندا
التمييز ازمه اخرى اذرع المنتخبات
الاوروبيه ليست مفتوحه دائما لابناء
المهاجرين وعندما نفوز فنحن ابناء الدوله
لكن عندما نخسر فنحن ابناء المهاجرين
صرخه مشتركه اطلقها اكثر من نجوم